[Music]
in the world of comic books you have
these characters who operate in a world
that's either black or white an
anti-hero kind of lives in that gray
area
does the things that we've not typically
seen from Heroes he does the things that
they won't do to get the job done
I like characters that walk that fine
line between doing the right thing and
doing what needs to be done
Black Adam will bring the bad guy to
Justice Black Adam Justice
the Black Adam is a hero to his people
of conduct he's their champion
his Black Adam doesn't save condoc no
one will you could really use a
superhero right about now
I'm not hero
extremely intense but there's a tone of
intensity mixed with levity that he has
not a lot of Heroes who pulled that off
you better not drop those prisoners I'm
not going to drop them I'm going to drop
one of them
is a man who is really tortured there's
demons within him there's a lot of pain
behind his eyes
haunted by the loss of what he had
[Music]
the cross is a particular line where
there's more room for savagery without
accountability
generals don't kill people well I do I
know the power of Black Adam those are
the kind of superhero super villain
qualities that changes the game and can
take the power and turn it on its head
have the power to be the destroyer of
this world but you can also be its
savior
my son sacrificed his life to save me
his powers
are not a gift
but a curse
born out of Rage
[Music]
I don't know
this Loose Cannon needs to be locked
down before innocent people start
getting hurt
it's been asleep for 5 000 years
you find us a cell that can hold we'll
take care of the rest who's on the team
I didn't bring a passport we don't need
passports
we're the Justice Society
we're here to negotiate your peaceful
surrender
I'm not peaceful
nor do I Surrender
here we go
I kneel before no one
you didn't come here to seek Justice
you came to exact Revenge
[Music]
I never said I was a hero
you believe you are not worthy
but fate does not make mistakes
[Music]
you can be the destroyer of this world
[Music]
or you can be its savior
foreign
[Music]